what did you say my collections complete
what you think I'm I know what the [ __ ]
that was the one who has everything
oh but there's a phrase out there that
we hear from a lot of people when we
succeed in something that we're doing
what does that phrase us it is I'm so
proud of you that's right I'm so proud
oh yeah
no here's the thing I don't have a
proper that phrase in fact I love it
when other people congratulate others
when they do a great job a plus on that
day bring about doctor first [ __ ] or
different Belgium is so funny
that the people who always tell you that
they're proud of you are the ones you
don't give a [ __ ] about I'm talking
about the [ __ ] that never
talked to you before and in fact some of
these people that say ain't proud of you
are the [ __ ] that explicitly
said they hated your [ __ ] guts
because when you do something great the
people that quote-unquote hate your
[ __ ] guts what a piece of that
success jump all of them for him when
you had to pick his nose and I was like
meeting me and all sudden you start
bringing out stories like you guys were
best friends and [ __ ] I'm not once I'm
done it's on your back now if I scratch
scratch no huh you owner and I think the
reason why it bothers us so much because
it's such a conniving thing to do that's
right because a lot of us out there we
[ __ ] work hard and the people that
were there from the beginning supporting
and Rudy or the reason why that you are
where you're at right now so all those
people that come towards the end they
put that hand on the shoulder they say
hey ain't proud of you yes I am proud of
myself too that I haven't gotten a
bazooka blew you the [ __ ] out up because
a time like this when you do other
people that you think about are the
people that were there for you when you
needed them the most the people that
were there for you when you were nobody
you were penniless and they are
always there for you despite anything
that's going on are the people that
should say that they are proud of you
and those are the ones that mean the
most and you know what comes hand in
hand with the phrase I'm proud of you is
I missed your bro and make you a man dad
I miss you it's like a [ __ ] thing
that like every time you see some do
that you met once they say I miss you
[ __ ] you didn't miss me and they said
what you asked me if I missed you you
missed me no brother I think about you
watching a lot cuz I don't like you I
don't like you the first time I met you
I don't like you the second time I met
you and the third time you left you
still alive you know what the funny
thing is in my case I'm on YouTube I'm
[ __ ] you to what what am I gonna do
for you give you a couple subscribers
get your [ __ ] life again understand
what the [ __ ] is without these people I
don't get it what are you trying to
prove you're not proud of me you don't
even like me just say it say you [ __ ] me
it makes me feel better
[ __ ] sound like a broken Drake
record the [ __ ] I thought uncle I'm so
proud of you
I'm so proud of you and so proud of you
because the moment you do something
great these people that append yeah whoa